a
[Música]
los registros civiles de china
recibieron a principios de año una
avalancha de solicitudes de divorcio no
se debía una crisis nacional de amor
sino a la inminente entrada en vigor de
una ley que obliga a los cónyuges a
pasar por un mes de enfriamiento o de
reflexión desde que presentan los
documentos hasta que empiezan a ser
tramitados esa ley que no se aplica a
los supuestos de violencia conyugal fue
aprobada a pesar de las masivas críticas
que recibió de la población que la
entendía como una intromisión
inaceptable del gobierno en asuntos
privados ese mes de reflexión busca
reducir el número de divorcios
impetuosos de las parejas más jóvenes
los divorcios se han triplicado en china
desde que fueron legalizados en 2003 así
que los chinos cada vez se casan más
tarde o no se casan y se divorcian más a
menudo y esa nueva concepción de la
familia es una de las causas por las que
la natalidad ha caído a sus niveles
históricos más bajos a pesar de la
derogación de la política del hijo único
[Música]
los egipcios se casan menos y se
divorcian más el número de divorcios se
ha triplicado en la última década
solamente entre 2018 y 2019 ascendió a
más de 200.000 subió un 7% con respecto
al año anterior mientras que el de
matrimonios descendió casi un 3% algo
que preocupa a las autoridades locales
que intentan animar a los egipcios a que
se lo piensen dos veces antes de acabar
en los tribunales por ese motivo un
abogado ha propuesto el matrimonio de
prueba algo que no es como tal un
matrimonio de pruebas sino un tipo de
contrato prematrimonial en el que ambas
partes expresarían los mínimos para que
prosiga la convivencia en el caso de
producirse la separación los mínimos con
que deberían ser compensados algo que ya
estipula la ley pero que sin embargo
mantiene a muchas mujeres durante años
en los tribunales la propuesta desató
furor en las redes sociales para bien y
para mal y tiene muy preocupadas a las
autoridades religiosas que no quieren
que esa franja entre los 30 y los 35
años que es la más afectado por
y tomando decisiones de las que luego se
arrepienta
[Música]
filipinas es junto al vaticano el único
país del mundo que no ha legalizado el
divorcio algo que supone un drama para
millones de mujeres filipinas atrapadas
en matrimonios donde sus cónyuges
ejercen de manera sistemática la
violencia física o psicológica las
alternativas no son sencillas por un
lado está la separación que permite por
ejemplo separar bienes pero que obliga a
la mujer a conservar el apellido de su
esposo y a requerir también de su firma
para determinados trámites legales otra
opción es la anulación pero se trata de
un trámite muy largo y complejo que
cuesta de media unos seis mil dólares
una cantidad que muy pocos pueden
permitirse en filipinas aquellos que
defienden la necesidad de legalizar el
divorcio en el país asiático argumenta
que se trata de defender derechos
básicos para la mujer mientras que los
políticos que abogan por mantener
intacta la legislación defienden que el
divorcio destruiría una institución como
el matrimonio en un país donde el 80 por
ciento de la población es católica y
donde la iglesia ejerce un rol muy
importante para mantener intacta la ley
[Música]